AUDIENCE.
YOU ARE NOT SORRY.
WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
TONIGHT WE ARE TRACKING MULTIPLE
BREAKING SCORES INCLUDING
HORRIFIC DETAILS FROM THE 6th
WOMAN ACCUSING ANDREW CUOMO OF
SEXUAL MISCONDUCT.
A REPORT FROM THE ALBANY TIMES
UNION OUT TONIGHT.
THIS STAFFER NOT NAMED YET WAS
ALLEGEDLY ASSAULTED INSIDE THE
GOVERNOR’S PRIVATE RESIDENCE
WHILE SHE WAS ON LOCATION TO FIX
AN ISSUE WITH HIS MOBILE PHONE.
SHE CLAIMS HE SHUT THE DOOR AND
FONDLEDER BODY UNDER HER BLOUSE.
GOVERNOR CUOMO IS DENYING THE
ALLEGATION BUT IF TRUE THIS
COULD SPELL THE END FOR GOVERNOR
ANDREW CUOMO.
PLUS THE LATEST FROM OUR CRISIS
AT THE WIDE OPEN SOUTH FLORIDA.
--
-- SOUTHERN BORDER.
SENATOR MARK KELLY, WHERE ARE
YOU?
PEOPLE OF ARIZONA DESERVE TO
KNOW.
LATER A FULL REPORT ON THE
DEMOCRAT’S LATEST EFFORT TO
DESTROY YOUR SECOND AMENDMENT.
THIS IS NOT A TEST.
THIS IS A CLEAR AND PRESENT
DANGER ON YOUR SECOND ASSESSMENT
RIGHTS.
FIRST JUST AFTER 9 P.M. ON THE
EAST COAST, 6 P.M. ON THE WEST
COAST.
IT’S 2 HOURS AFTER JOE BIDEN’S
BED TIME.
HE’S LIKELY FAST ASLEEP AFTER
A LONG AND EXHAUSTING WEEK FOR
THE PRESIDENT.
YESTERDAY HE MANAGED TO HAVE ONE
AGENDA ITEM AND HOLD ONE PUBLIC
EVENT.
AGAIN TODAY, JUST ONE VERY
SHORT, SCRIPTED SPEECH WHERE HE
WAS STRUGGLING TO KEEP HIS FOCUS
ON THE TINY LITTLE LETTERS AND
WORDS IN THE TELEPROMPTER.
LOOK AT HIS EYES HERE.
HE IS DIGGING IN DEEP.
LOCKING IN.
JUST TO GET THROUGH THE PREPARED
REMARKS.
JOE DOES ONE EVENT A DAY.
IT LOOKS LIKE HE NEEDS A NAP
DESPERATELY.
STILL NO PRESS CONFERENCE.
NO JOINT TO CONGRESS THE STATE
OF THE UNION AND HIS
VICE-PRESIDENT KAMALA HARRIS IS
TAKING SOLO CALLS WITH WORLD
LEADER WHICH IS THE
COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF’S JOB.
THE BIDEN BLITZ IS COMING.
AN ARTICLE BIDEN HAS BEEN
HUNKERED DOWN FOR WEEKS NOT
BECAUSE HE IS FRAIL, BUT BECAUSE
HE HAD TO ORGANIZE THE
VACCINATION DISTRIBUTION PLAN,
THE ONE DONALD TRUMP ORGANIZED
AND HANDED OVER TO HIM WITH 3
DIFFERENT VACCINES AND JOE HAD
NOTHING TO DO WITH THE
1.9-TRILLION DOLLARS SCHUMER AND
PELOSI PAY OFF BILL.
BIDEN WILL PROBABLY HOLD MORE
PUBLIC EVENTS IN COMING WEEKS
INCLUDING TOMORROW’S REMARK
ABOUT COVID-1919.
HE HAS BEEN PRACTICING AND HE
WILL BE FINE.
IT WILL BE OVER.
HE WILL HAVE PRACTICED ALL DAY
TODAY.
IT TELL BE A SHORT, SCRIPTED
SPEECH.
THEY WILL MAKE THE FONT REALLY,
REALLY BIG SO HE DOESN’T HAVE TO
SQUINT AND DIAL THE WAY WE SAW
TODAY.
JOE CAN SURVIVE THE STATE OF THE
UNION ADDRESS.
YOU READ 2 LINES, THEN YOU PAUSE
FOR APPLAUSE AND READ 3 MORE
LINES AND PAUSE.
IT’S PERFECTLY SUITED FOR JOE.
SLOW, COMFORTABLE PACE FOR JOE
BIDEN.
SUITED FOR SOMEBODY THAT IS WEEK
AND STRUGGLING.
PEOPLE WILL SAY, SEE, SEAN
HANNITY, HE IS TOTALLY FINE.
THERE IS ONE BIG PROBLEM.
ANYONE WITH EYES AND EARS CAN
SEE AND HEAR JOE IS NOT FINE.
SOURCES CLOSE TO IT THE WHITE
HOUSE ARE DESCRIBING HOW
COMPLETE PANIC SET IN ALL THINGS
IN BIDEN’S WORLD.
YESTERDAY’S NEW POLL REVEALED
HALF OF THE COUNTRY IS WORRIED
THAT JOE BIDEN IS NOT PHYSICALLY
OR MENTALLY UP TO THE JOB HAS
ADDED DRAMATICALLY TO THE
BEHIND-THE-SCENES PANIC IN THE
BIDEN WHITE HOUSE.
AN OP-ED IN THE WASHINGTON
"TIMES" RESIDES:
IT’S TIME TO QUESTION BIDEN’S
MENTAL HEALTH.
THERE WON’T BE A BLITZ.
MR. PRESIDENT, WILL YOU ANSWER
A QUESTION?
THANKS, WE HAVE TO GO.
IT WILL THAT KIND OF BLITZ.
PRESIDENT TRUMP TALKED TO THE
PRESIDENT EVERY DAY.
FRANKLY HE MIGHT HAVE TALKED TOO
MUCH TO THE PRESS.
I DON’T THINK DONALD TRUMP WAS
EVER ASLEEP BEFORE 1 A.M. DURING
HIS PRESIDENCY.
THIS BIDEN BLITZ WILL PROBABLY
CONSIST OF HIM GIVING A FEW
SPEECHES WRITTEN BY HIS STAFF.
KEPT SHORT ALONG WITH
ORCHESTRATED AND CONTROLLED
PUBLIC OUTINGS.
IT WON’T MATTER.
WE CAN ALREADY SEE THAT JOE LOST
HIS FAST BALL, CURVEBALL, AND
KNUCKLEBALL AND EVEN A SLOW
PITCH.
WE HAVE VIDEO TO COMPARE JOE
BIDEN IN 2012 AND 2016 FROM THE
LAST 3 WEEKS.
THIS ONLY VIDEO OF JOE FROM THE
AS ALWAYS WE LET YOU DECIDE.
>> HE SENT ME 2 LETTERS SAYING
BY THE WAY CAN YOU SEND ME SOME
STIMULUS MONEY FOR COMPANIES
HERE IN THE STATE OF WISCONSIN?
WE SENT MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
>> YOU KNOW, THE IDEA THAT,
HMMM -- CARRY A CARD WITH ME
EVERY DAY WITH THE FULL NUMBER
OF FOLKS.
>> Sean: NOW THEY HAVE A NEW
PLAN TCHT WON’T TRUST YOU
ANYMORE.
FOLLOW YOUR INSTINCTS.
>> I WANT TO THANK THE FORMER
GENERAL.
I KEEP CALLING HIM GENERAL.
MY GUY -- THE GUY WHO RUNS THAT
OUTFIT OVER THERE.
I WANT TO MAKE SURE WE THINK THE
SECRETARY.
>> THEY PUT ONE FOOT IN FRONT OF
THE OTHER.
THEY KEEP GOING.
THAT’S THE UNBREAKABLE SPIRIT OF
THE PEOPLE OF AMERICA.
THAT’S WHO WE ARE.
>> AND REPRESENTATIVES, HMMM,
LEE AND GREEN AND GARCIA.
EXCUSE ME.
PIN -- WHAT AM I DOING HERE?
I AM GOING TO LOSE TRACK.
>> Sean: LOSE TRACK AGAIN.
WE WILL ASK THE QUESTION THE
MEDIA MOB IS AFRAID TO ASK BUT
KNOW IS HAPPENING.
WHAT IS GOING ON WITH THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
OF AMERICA JOE BIDEN.
IS THERE SOMETHING MEDICALLY
WRONG HERE.
WE THE PEOPLE HAVE ENOUGH TO
KNOW.
PEOPLE TOLD ME, YOU NEED TO BE
MORE COMPASSIONATE TO JOE.
THIS IS SUPPOSED TO THE LEADER
OF THE FREE WORLD.
THIS IS SUPPOSED TO BE OUR
COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF.
IT’S THE HARDEST JOB ON EARTH
WHICH IS WHERE THE MEDIA JOB AND
BIG TECH SHOULD NOT HAVE CREATED
THE CANDIDATE PROTECTION
PROGRAM.
THIS MATTERS BIG TIME FOR THE
ENTIRE WORLD.
YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT
COMPASSION?
I WOULD ARGUE COMPASSION SHOULD
HAVE COME FROM ALL THE PEOPLE
AROUND JOE BIDEN THAT KNEW OF
HIS STRUGGLES AND WORKED OVER
TIME TO HIDE AND COVER-UP ALL OF
THIS AND HIDE VITAL INFORMATION
ABOUT A PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE
FROM YOU, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
WHERE WAS THEIR COMPASSION FOR
JOE?
LIKE, FOR EXAMPLE, JOE’S FRIENDS
IN THE MEDIA MOB, HAD NO PROBLEM
RAISING COGNITIVE CONCERNS ABOUT
RONALD REAGAN AND JOHN MCCAIN.
>> IF WE WINS THE GENERAL
ELECTION HE WILL BE THE OLDEST
PERSON TO IT ASSUME THE
PRESIDENCY.
>> HE IS GETTING UP ON UPPER END
OF THE COMFORT ZONE FOR
AMERICANS WHO WONDER IF HE WILL
HAVE THE VIGOR AND THE HEALTH AS
PRESIDENT.
>> MCCAIN’S OBAMA BARACK OBAMA
WILL SOON BE 47.
>> Sean: THERE WERE MANY MORE
QUESTIONS RAISED ABOUT RONALD
REAGAN IN 1984.
THE "WASHINGTON POST" WONDERED
IF REAGAN LOST HIS OLD FIRE WITH
AGE.
AN ARTICLE IN THE "NEW YORK
TIMES" TITLED THE AGE ISSUE
CLAIMS THAT REAGAN’S ADVISORS
KNEW HE WAS STRUGGLING AND THIS
IS WHY THEY KEEP HIM OUT OF
PRESS CONFERENCES AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE.
AGE MAY HAVE BEEN A FACTOR IN
HIS FALTERING PERFORMANCE.
WHAT DOES THE "NEW YORK TIMES"
SAY ABOUT JOE BIDEN BEING KEPT
AWAY FROM THE PRESS?
WATCH THIS.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> [INAUDIBLE].
>> [SHOUTING].
>> WE ARE GOING TO MOVE ON.
>> MR. PRESIDENT, CAN YOU PASS
VOTING RIGHTS WITH THE
FILIBUSTER?
>> [SHOUTING].
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> THANK YOU.
BYE-BYE.
>> MR. PRESIDENT, WHEN WILL YOU
UNVEIL THE BUILD BACK BETTER
PROGRAM?
>> I AM HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS
IF THAT’S WHAT I AM SUPPOSED TO
DO.
WHATEVER YOU WANT ME TO DO.
>> [BEEPING].
>> Sean: WHO MADE THAT DECISION
TO GO TO BARS AND TONE?
THE "NEW YORK TIMES" OR
"WASHINGTON POST" THEY REPORT ON
JOE BIDEN’S OBVIOUS STRUGGLES OR